bien estamos en la sección de ejercicios
de fracciones en la recta numérica del
sitio khan academy y nos preguntan mueve
el punto naranja a tres cuartos en la
recta numérica primero modifica el
número de divisiones para crear las
marcas en la recta numérica veamos qué
es lo que tenemos pues bien tenemos el
espacio que va del 0 al 1 en la recta
numérica y si yo quisiera indicar el
tres cuartos entonces tendría que
dividir este espacio entre el 0 y el 1
en cuartos en cuatro espacios iguales
bien ya hicimos cuatro divisiones en
este espacio
un cuarto aquí tenemos otro cuarto aquí
tenemos otro cuarto y aquí uno más
así que si quiero llegar a tres cuartos
muevo a un cuarto me muevo un cuarto más
para llegar a dos cuartos un cuarto más
para llegar a tres cuartos y ahí lo
tienes llegamos a tres cuartos